All right, well we've got one incredible teen
who just made aviation history.
This story moves me so much, okay.
CNN reports 19 year old Zara Rutherford
has become the youngest woman to fly around the world solo.
This brave young pilot spent 260 hours in flight,
with stops in 41 countries,
for a distance of 32,000 miles.
She faced weather, VISA delays, stuck in Alaska and Russia,
got banned from China's airspace, but for five months
she did this.
Wow.
And then she landed, full circle to her home in Belgium.
Her first stop was her favorite sandwich shop,
a girl after my own heart.
You're like changing the world and breaking records,
but you're still thinking about that home-town sandwich.
Can you imagine your friend, your sibling,
anyone you know accomplishing something like this?
She was over Siberia and the winds were so crazy,
she was scared, like it was her most fearful apparently.
She flew over the Atlantic and the clouds were so bad,
she had to fly 1,500 feet above water.
Wow.
For nine hours straight.
What type of bravery? Zara you are literally my hero.
(audience cheering)
Yeah.
And what will she do next? That's exciting.
And what will she do next?
We got our eye on you.
Well, next up, this TikTok is going viral
for take a very strong stance on engagement ring etiquette.
The Independent reports, Madison Write,
the founder of Madberet Jewelry, posted this short,
but very clear message about what to do
when you're gonna propose.
This is a message of everyone who will propose one day.
The ring should not be a surprise,
but how and when you propose should be a surprise.
So, okay, wait.
I want everyone to weigh in on this,
Right?
Please.
Agree to pick the ring together, raise of hands.
What are your names, may I ask?
Yes, I'm Lisa and Val Matula. This is my Valentine.
His name is Valentine.
Wait, your real name is Valentine?
Yes, yeah.
Yes.
Oh, I love you!
As was my dad's, going back five generations.
But his birthday is February 16th,
he'll be 65, on February 16th.
Oh, wow.
So I always have my Valentine with me.
That's so cute.
Yeah.
So 35 years and we picked out the ring together.
But he surprised me with it a couple weeks later,
because it was being made.
Yeah.
So I didn't know.
Neither did I.
Yeah, so this is my best friend.
The thing about what we did is good advice,
because planning ahead, planning together,
is part of a strong marriage, but keeping surprises in there
is the other part.
Yes, agreed.
(audience applauding)
Agreed Drew.
My heart is like a cartoon right now.
I mean, if anyone wants to disagree after that,
show of hands.
Well, I'll just agree a little bit with you,
because I do agree
that you shouldn't spring the ring, right?
It shouldn't be a total surprise, but there should be
a little collaboration.
But there needs to be the essence of secrecy.
Like for example, when I proposed to Wellie,
I did a thing where we were in a mall, and I was like,
"Oh, you wanna like go to a jewelry store
and like laugh at jewelry?
(Ross fake laughs)
All right, oh I hate that. I like that, do you like that?
Do you like?" So I kinda got some intel.
But he didn't know I was gonna like pick,
we didn't pick it out together,
'cause I wanted to surprise him,
I wanted to, you know, knock him off his feet a little bit.
So I love the idea that you guys collaborated,
and then the engagement's a surprise.
But I wouldn't wanna see the ring before.
I want you to get my essence and then figure it out.
I don't think there's a right or a wrong.
It depends on the person.
Like I know Wellington wanted me to pick it and design it,
but if someone were proposing to me,
you better believe I wanna pick that ring out first.
Well see, there you go!
You better believe it.
There you go.
(upbeat theme music)